hi guys welcome to the just brilliant
songs youtube channel today i'm going to
be reacting to first day out by t
grizzy i've never heard of this song
before the reason i picked this song
was because you guys voted on my
instagram if you don't already follow me
on instagram
i do polls on which songs i should react
to next so this one won that's why i'm
doing it today
also do not forget to like comment and
subscribe especially subscribe as you
guys know i'm trying to make a career
out of this and every subscriber
helps all right i'm a i'm a star i'm
kind of excited
honestly
okay we got a prison these [ __ ] prayed
on my downfall
these [ __ ] prayed on my downfall on
our team [ __ ] i stood the tour you did
show these disloyal [ __ ] how to ball
go get a thermometer for the pot
i need this [ __ ] cooked right let's keep
that water 400 degrees fahrenheit
you ever been inside a federal courtroom
[ __ ] you ever went to trial and fought
for your life
so this is a little bit different than a
lot of the songs that i've listened to
this is like kind of emotional
so he's talking about being in prison
he's talking about how he went to court
um and he's also talking about how we
taught people how to ball
i play basketball i get it honestly
being broke did something to my spirit
ass [ __ ] to plug me they act like they
couldn't hear me
look at me not driving german
engineering y'all want your baby mama
[ __ ] keep the hoe from near me kilroy
remember when i used to use your ills to
hit the road hit the o and make them big
boy seals
move remember when you had them bring
things made with vacuum seals trying not
to have them green things smell fast was
on me what you know about related
so it looks like he's talking about how
he was broke before
maybe in prison and now he's
out of prison and doing bigger and
better things like driving nice cars
yeah i'm gonna keep going any further
questions you could take that out with
the lawyer my [ __ ] finger j money break
my low price jake joe i'll tell you
ready day before school i sold a half
bowl how you think i won best dressed
with no support
and had them paid lawyers coming in and
out of court hey window
at yo ain't it a blessing we made it off
kentucky after all that happened
after the pre-trials after the status
after the impact statements after the
castle hey j.r
[ __ ] ain't it a blessing we made it out
of lansing after all that happened
after michigan so it looks like a lot of
stuff
this like is making me really like this
is kind of it seems
deep um i don't understand it fully but
it looks like
there was a lot of like stuff that
happened so it looks like he went to
jail
maybe he was broke for a while then got
out of jail
and now he's doing bigger and better
things and he's kind of reminiscing on
what happened
when our man told honors the bands they
took from us joyro [ __ ] with the money
longest six mile break
knock your box down pick her up
knuckleback tracks up yes i slap girl
yes i slap dog yes i slap loud yes i
slap a [ __ ] [ __ ] if he act out okay
this song just took a turn
this song just took a turn so it looks
like initially
he was like all emotional and now he's
kind of talking about
the same stuff in the previous songs
like getting money girls
um and he also talked about how he was
best dressed i'm going to continue
cases on a roll with them killers bro
kill me if i snitches if you snitch i'm
going to kill you
he says kill me if i snitch because if
you snitch
i'm going to kill you this is important
for a lot of reasons snitching
not good especially in the rap
community they make it very clear so
he's saying he would never snitch and if
you snitch
you're dead time on the yard with them
gorillas stood tall did i let [ __ ]
help me quit being silly i know [ __ ]
your [ __ ] [ __ ] get wet for a [ __ ]
cause i do it better plus i'm doing
better than [ __ ]
i'm at home when i'm down nearing
lexington [ __ ] about the king they
gonna drop you in who next to you [ __ ]
he says they're gonna drop you and who's
next to you
so i think dropping means killing
so if they say they're gonna drop you
and
who's next to you they're gonna kill you
and whoever's next to you i think this
is referring
to the snitch statement get ahead of
them [ __ ] when you take off i'll look
back and try to rescue them [ __ ] i
catch
mans to make sure you get the rest of
them [ __ ] don't let me get the best of
you just get the revenue [ __ ] let's get
it so let me know what you can handle
okay congrats here goes some extras so
if i'm busy you can manage things happy
bling dancing
60 dollars i need a challenge
so he's just referring to different ways
that he has money he's referring to some
jewelry
he's saying there's a 60 dollar salad
the the message here
is i got money and you know what he's
proud of what he got
and he was broke and in jail at the
beginning of the song so i think that
goes into why he's so proud
[Music]
don't entertain them hungry [ __ ] i
wish i would pay attention to these
homeless [ __ ]
walk on my phone i don't wanna do no
song with [ __ ] and tell your [ __ ] to
tighten up before i bomb
so i see a um
actually let me listen to this part
again
at me when they sober on parole i'm a
feeling you think i ain't got that
gloria you right bro take his head off
his [ __ ]
[Music]
i wish i would pay attention so he's
saying he doesn't entertain
hungry people so when he says hungry
i think he's referring to people that
are like
hungry for his money so he's not
these homeless people like he already
got his bag you got to figure out your
own bag
now there's a very pretty woman bringing
him some cash
for my phone i don't want to do no song
and tell your [ __ ] to tighten up before
i bought her [ __ ] i don't know
so he's saying tell your girl to tighten
up before i bone her so
this just means tell your girl for her
vagina to tighten up before he has sex
with her
um it's an interesting point but you
know it it is what it i'm going to
continue
through these white buffs i could see
the hoe and [ __ ] free my [ __ ]
call that boy be horn [ __ ] speed shoot
the smile off your face
with [ __ ] so he's saying he can't
trust you with his gun if you don't have
any bodies i thought body meant body
count
as in people you've slept with but i
learned
that a body means someone you've shot
a little different than what i thought
on top of that
what else did what did he say before
that hold up my phone i don't want to do
no songs
and tell your [ __ ] to tighten up before
i bought her [ __ ] i don't know you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wrong with [ __ ] through these
white buffs i could see the hoe and
[ __ ]
free my [ __ ] call that boy be horn
[ __ ] spit shoot the smile off your face
oh yeah he's saying i'm gonna shoot the
smile off your face so he's saying i
will shoot you
if you joke with me he is not a guy that
likes some jokes
he does not want to play around he's
saying
i got guns i'm hard well i can't trust
you with that strap if you ain't got no
bodies
well i can't take you on no lick if you
ain't rob nobody you ain't no shooter
you can't do that [ __ ] without no molly
i came home and had the halls weathered
in kalahari 30 months ago
so he's saying he can't trust you if you
haven't shot anybody or robbed anybody
and then he goes home and gets girls
this is ladies we need to raise our
standards
i'm not saying my standards are crazy
high
i'm not saying you gotta like date a
millionaire or anything but
i do think that we can have the standard
of
you shouldn't date someone that shot or
killed somebody
call me old-fashioned i know i know
[ __ ] ain't think that i was coming
home shout out to them [ __ ] freaks
that i've been coming on get them to the
crib bust them down that [ __ ] run
this s.k.a get to shaking like it's
something wrong 30 bands 2 times watch
this money club the feds say my name hot
like when the oven on
[ __ ] i came home to my little brother
going [ __ ] say they looking for me
pull up in the skutty zone
who said i'm a snitch you just heard a
lot from him better check the black and
white that paperwork of off for him
zero toleration for that [ __ ] take his
life from him he don't want that pistol
plate okay i take some yo
i ain't hear from [ __ ] when i had
them blues on so soon as i'm done
[ __ ] put your shoes on
you said i didn't hear from [ __ ] when
i had the blues on
i don't know what the blues means like
is he talking about like a blue
color scheme i don't think it's that
because that seems like it would be a
little bit
more like like i don't think that would
make a difference but
it seems like a girl didn't want him for
something
whatever blues means so then after he
hooks up with her he's like you didn't
want me before
so put your shoes on see ya
not a very nice thing to do on either
end i'm on parole in two states i can't
move
the fed is trying to build a case i
can't move i want the trial back to back
[ __ ] i'm chewing
so he's saying that the feds are trying
to build a case against him
and he's been to trial but he's two
enough so he won both of those
i don't know if that's something to brag
about that's just me
i wouldn't brag about that but you know
what you do you
kentucky banned me from mary jury stuff
i can't even be in public with my hoodie
michigan state no one over here they
don't know witty on i know they prayed
on my downfall i already know that
i know they prayed on my downfall so
he's saying that people preyed on his
downfall so people
were looking for him to mess up honestly
guys
people don't care like
just do your thing nobody's sitting
there praying for you to
to downfall like i promise
i i mean where maybe i'm wrong i don't
know
i don't know a team [ __ ] i stood ten
toes [ __ ] so these loyal [ __ ] had a
boy
oh so it looks like i just had a
realization at the end of the song
it looks like michigan was where he went
to prison so he had referencing michigan
like we made it out of michigan
and i didn't know why but i guess that's
where the prison is
um i think this song okay i liked it for
some reason
i didn't think the messaging was great
like he's basically saying
i don't snitch snitches are bad um i did
a bunch of illegal things and now i'm
bragging about it
i don't know he talks a lot about
loyalty and people that weren't loyal
messaging but i did like the switch up
like in the beginning of the song it was
super emotional
and then later it became more
like i don't know like it came like like
a bop you know like a bop so
i would give this song like a 7 out of
10. i think it was cool
but again the messaging is gonna take
three away from me
let me know in the comments do you agree
with my analysis do you disagree
either way leave a comment let me know
if i missed anything do not forget to
subscribe
to my channel again every subscriber
helps me build a career out of this
i appreciate all of you and while you're
at it leave a like you're already doing
a comment and a subscribe so leave a
like too
i will talk to you guys next time